Let's Play a Very Simple Game Jan and Zara
Will Tell Us How They've Been Working Hard on
Constructing a Triangle We Just Have to Find Out If We're
Telling the Truth First Let's Hear Jan Out He Tells Us That He
Constructed a Triangle
in Which the Lengths of the  Sides are
2 cm 3 cm and 5 cm is common telling as the truth Let's find out we
should use the
triangle equality them to find this out the sum
of any two sides should be greater than the third
side so calculate the sum of any two  side
and if it is greater than the third
side let's find out the sum of the first two
sides it is 2 + 3 w e the third side it is
5 and we know that 2 + 3 e e 5 but the sum of the two
sides is 2  B greater than the third side It means that a triangle
with sides toothed
and 5 cm cannot be formed Jan was lying now
Zara wants to tell us about the
triangle she
constructed She tells us that the length of the
sides of that triangle are 3 4  And 5
cm is just telling the truth Let's make a small
table to note the sum of two sides and the
third side Remember based on the theorem we
learn the sum of any two sides should be greater than
the third side The sum of first two sides
is 3+ 4 and the third side is even 3+ 4 is
greater than 5 We can conclude as the truth
is not even though we have just looked at one of the
cases Now let us consider the next
combination 4 + 5 The other side is 3  And the sum which equals
9 is greater than 3 Now for the
last combination which is 3 + 5 The remaining
side is 4 and 3+ 5 is greater than 4 so we can see that
the condition is satisfied for all
three cases it means that a  Triangle with
sides 3 4 and 5 cm can be formed as shown in
[Music]
Truth